testing shortage makes it difficult to
find out exactly who has a corona virus
Ohio's top health official says she
suspects more than a hundred thousand
people in her state have the virus even
though only five people have tested
positive so far many are being told to
self quarantine if they may have come in
close contact with someone who does have
the virus so what does a self quarantine
look like our doctor Tara Narula visited
vladimir duthiers at his apartment to
give him some tips on how to protect
your loved ones if you were asked to
stay at home Vlad has been working from
his New York apartment since Wednesday
when we closed our New York office after
three employees tested positive for the
virus they are Vlad good morning it's
nice to see the apartment over good
morning everyone
welcome to Maison jus Tia to be clear I
am NOT under quarantine but what's
really important if you believe you've
come into contact with the corona virus
the CDC recommends that you self
quarantine for at least two weeks if
you've got no symptoms after that you
should be in the clear but if you are
living in close quarters with others
self quarantine can be a real challenge
Jessica Haller lives in the Bronx and
has been home with her four kids since
last Tuesday they're under a
precautionary quarantine after a case of
corona virus was confirmed in their
school others facing quarantine are also
unsure about the best ways to protect
their loved ones if confined for two
weeks when our dr. Tara Narula visited
my home you really do want to try to
keep your distance from your loved ones
she pointed to many unexpected places
where contagion can spread so you want
to be aware of high touch surfaces
things that you touch over and over
again whether that's the faucet handle
whether that's a countertop or you're
preparing food the refrigerator door and
all of these things you should be
disinfecting you also want to use your
own dishware and utensils and cups so
maybe pick a couple that you're just
going to use for those 14 days that are
your own so all those remotes need to be
wiped down okay okay
also iPads iPhones any sort of devices
that you're use
you're gonna want to wipe down us well
what's helpful to keep the room well
ventilated and the air circulating so if
you do live in a place that you can open
the windows it's not too cold out that
would be one other thing to think about
doing the haulers are taking extra
precautions for now they use FaceTime to
communicate with their grandpa who was
recently released from the hospital for
another illness they don't know for sure
when they'll return to school all right
dr. Narula also says if you're getting
any kind of deliveries food deliveries
grocery deliveries you should leave them
outside of your door leave the money
outside of the door too she also pointed
us to a CDC website page that actually
has a list of approved cleaning agents
bleach disinfectant wipes they work very
important to take a look at that page
also very important if you are on
medication and you maybe need to be self
quarantine for two weeks make sure you
have enough on hand Anthony a lot of
very good advice there Vlad and thank
you for the house tour by the way come
over some day cruise having breakfast
afterwards have their own plates right